[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم احالت الحكومه المصريه على
الرئيس الموقت نسخه من مشروع قانون يشترط
الاختار لتنظيم الاجتماعات والمواكب
والتظاهرات في الاماكن العامه ويعاقب
مخالفيه بالحبس والغرامه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين دوافع ودلالات
السعي لاصدار هذا القانون في الظرف
السياسي الراهن في
مصر هل يقيد هذا التشريع احد مكتسبات ثوره
يناير ام ينظمه فقط وما مدى قدره الحكومه
الحاليه على
تطبيقه حق التظاهر انتزعه المصريون في
ثوره الخ من يناير وتمسكت به كافه القوى
السياسيه من بعد خلال حكم المجلس العسكري
وفي ظل اول رئيس منتخب الا انه بات محل
جدل فيما بعد ال 30 من يونيو وتفجر
تظاهرات معارضي الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد
مرسي وفي هذا المناخ تسعى الحكومه المصريه
المؤقته لاصدار قانون تقول انه لتنظيم حق
التظاهر فيما يرى فيه حقوق وشخصيات سياسيه
بانه ينطوي على تقييد ورده على مكتسبات
ثوره يناير وقد قال عبد الغفار شكر نائب
رئيس المجلس القومي لحقوق الانسان ان هذا
القانون سيصدر لكي يموت بالسكته
القلبيه تنظيم الحق في الاجتماعات العامه
والمواكب والمظاهرات السلميه في الاماكن
العامه عنوان طويل لقانون التظاهر المنتظر
في مصر والجدل بشانه قد يكون اطول تسلم
الرئيس المصري المؤقت عدل منصور نسخه من
مشروع القانون
فالرئيس القوانين في ظل غياب مجلس تشريعي
يتكون مشروع القانون من 21 ماده ابرزها
حذر الاجتماع العام والمظاهرات في اماكن
العباده وحظر حمل اسلحه او ارتداء اقنعه
حذر تعطيل مصالح المواطنين وحركه المرور
يجوز لوزير الداخليه او مدير الامن المختص
الغاء الاجتماع العام او المظاهره او
ارجاؤها او نقلها الى مكان اخر يبدا فض
المظاهره بتوجيه انذار شفهي ثم استخدام
المياه ثم الغازات المسله للدموع واخيرا
الهراوات يمنع على قوه الامن استعمال اكثر
من ذلك الا في حالات الدفاع الشرعي عن
النفس حذر الاعتصام نهائيا ومنع الاقتراب
ب50 الى 100 متر من مقر الرئاسه والبرلمان
والحكومه والشرطه ينص المشروع على عقوبه
بالسجن والغرامه من 100000 الى 300000
جنيه لمخالفي قواعد الاخطار والمنتفعين
ماليا من تنظيم المظاهرات وصف حزب النور
السلفي المشروعه بانه قانون منع التظاهر
معبرا عن رفضه له بصيغته الحاليه في حين
قال قياديون في جبهه الانقاذ انه لا باس
به واوضح انه يحتاج الى بعض التعديلات
انتقد حزب الجبهه الديمقراطيه هذا القانون
مؤكدا ان تخوف حكومه الببلاوي من مظاهرات
جماعه الاخوان جعلها تقضي على اي مكتسبات
لثوره ال من يناير واضاف الحزب ان القانون
الذي سيصدر يشبه كثيرا القانون الذي
اقترحته حكومه هشام قنل خلال رئاسه محمد
مرسي ولقي معارضه شديده ممن هم الان في
الحكم الجدل لا يتعلق ببنود القانون فقط
بل ايضا بتوقيت طرحه في سياق سياسي محتقن
يفرض اولويات اهم واكبر
من نص لتقنين او تقييد المظاهرات في مصر
ما بعد من
يونيو لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نيويورك الكاتب والمحلل السياسي محمد
سطوحي وفي الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي وائل
قنديل اهلا بكما سيد سطوحي ما دلالات
اصدار هذا القانون او السعي لاصدار هذا
القانون في الظرف السياسي الراهن حاليا في
مصر
برايك مبدئيا يعني انا هنا يعني في
الولايات المتحده هناك قوانين تحكم
التظاهرات يعني نحن دائما كثيرا ما نعيد
اختراع
العجله اي تظاهره لابد ان يكون هناك قانون
منظم لها يحدد مسبقا موعد هذه المظاهرات
اين ستسير طريقه التعامل مع الجمهور
المحيط بها او المنشات العامه اي مخالفه
لها لابد ان يكون هناك ايضا ت المخالفات
فهناك امور وقواعد تعارف عليها العالم
الديمقراطي وبالتالي يعني يجب ان الا نعيد
اختراع العجله في كل مره نقترب من مثل هذه
القضايا لكن طبعا هناك في مصر وضع ربما
يكون استثنائيا في هذه اللحظه المقصود هنا
هو ان يكون هناك تنظيم للامن حفاظ على
الامن وفي نفس الوقت الا يكون هناك كبت
للحريات ومصادره على هذه الحريات خاصه في
المستقبل لانه نحن نتعامل مع ظرف ربما
يكون طارق في اللحظه الحاليه لكن يجب ايضا
الا نغفل عن الرؤيه الشامله لما يجب ان
تكون عليه مصر المستقبل هي مصر التي تحافظ
على حريه المواطنين وقدرتهم على التعبير
بشكل متوازن دون ان يمس بحريات وحقوق
الاخرين ا استيد والد قنديل ما ملاحظاتك
على هذا القانون مشروع القانون اولا هو
قانون فضفاض وطويل ومواد وفيه نوع من
الرطانه ونوع من الفسط الكثيره جدا
المق مضمون القانون من اوله الى نهايته
بيقول انه لم يعد مسموحا بالتظاهر في مصر
هناك ماده في هذا القانون بتلغي الاعتصام
تماما بتجرن فكره الاعتصام في حين ان لا
توجد مظاهره او لا يوجد اي نشاط احتجاجي
بدون اعتصام والاعتصام حق مشروع والاضراب
عن العمل حق مشروع ايضا وبالتالي هذا
قانون اراد تامين العصابه الحاكمه من اي
احتمالات للخروج عليها او بتعبير الفريق
عبد الفتاح السيسي التعبير الكوميدي
الركيك ايضا عندما قال ان الرئيس مرسي
استخدم الديمقراطيه سلما للوصول الى الحكم
واخذ السلم معه فوق هو بهذا القانون ايضا
استخدم التظاهرات والاعتصامات سلما
للانقلاب العسكري على الرئيس المنتخب
ويريد ان ياخذ معه السلم فوق ولا يسمح
لاحد بالتظاهر مره اخرى وكان هذا التظاهر
وحق الاعتصام كان مشروعا وكان محببا وكان
مبررا لاسقاط رئيس منتخب وصار مجرما بعد
ان تمت عمليه القرصنه على الديمقراطيه في
مصر والاطاحه بالرئيس محمد مرسي ولكنه
قريب من مواد قانون الي كان من المفترض ان
يصدر عندما كان مرسي في الحكم لا ليس
قريبا على الاطلاق ربما هو بعض الصياغات
قريبه ولكن عندما اكون بصدد قانون يلغي
الاعتصام ويجرم فكره الاعتصام تماما فانني
اكون بامام محاوله لوق اي احتجاج او لواد
اي نشاط معارضه حقيقيه في مصر القانون
القديم لم يكن يجرم الاعتصامات كان يكفل
حق الاعتصام والاضراب هذا القانون يجرم
الاعتصام بالاضافه الى بعض المواد الاخرى
التي تتحدث مثلا عن عدم الاقتراب او من
المؤسسات الرسميه اه زي رئاسه الجمهوريه
طيب انتم استخدمتم السلالم لتسلق قصر
الرئاسه تحت اشراف الجيش والشرطه وتحت
تشجيع من الجيش والشرطه ولم يكن ذلك مجرما
في ذلك الوقت من حق الناس ان تتساءل هنا
ما كان ما كان
مجرما او ما كان مشروعا ويلقى دعما رسميا
ايام الرئيس محمد مرسي صار مجرما الان
بالاضافه الى بعض الملاحظات الاخرى الفنيه
منها ما ذكره مثلا احد الضالعين في تاييد
هذا الانقلاب وهو السيد حافظ ابو سعد رئيس
المنظمه المصريه لحقوق الانسان فكره 100
متر الحرم الذي يبعد على المؤسسه الرسميه
لا يوجد شارع في مصر عرضه 100 متر
وبالتالي هذا يعني تجفيف المظاهرات وتجفيف
مظاهر الغضب والاحتجاج من
المنبع سيد محمد السطوحي اذا من الطبيعي
في اي دوله ان تنظم الاحتجاجات والتظاهرات
لكن القانون بحسب سيد وائل قنديل
هذا يقيد ولا ينظم ما
رايك
يعني انا عاوز اقول الاستاذ وائل القنديل
انه هذا المشروع لا يختلف كثيرا عن مشروع
الدكتور محمد مرسي للتظاهرات
لا ومساله انه الاعتصامات القانون السابق
كان يمنع كان يمنع نصب الخيام بعد التظاهر
والاقامه في مواقع المظاهرات و منظمات
حقوق الانسان كلها في العالم كله والامم
المتحده نددت بمشروع قانون الاخوان
المسلمين بالنسبه لتنظيم حق التظاهرات
وانا يعني للاسف انا كان معايا هذه
التصريحات لكن يعني هناك الكثير من الكلام
بشانها لكن مساله منع الاقتراب من المناطق
الحكوميه كان موجودا في المشروع السابق
على مسافه 200 متر كان يغرم من 20 الى
50,000 دولار يعني يعني كان يعطي الشرطه
حق فض المظاهرات بالقوه في حاله التزام
المنظمين باي باي من هذه التعليمات كان
يطلب من
المتظاهرين ان يبلغوا الشرطه قبل
المظاهرات وليس من حقهم تنظيمها في حاله
تنفيذ الشرطه لهذا الامر في حاله المخالفه
هم هو يعطيهم استخدام القوه لفض المظاهرات
يعني كل العيوب الموجوده في القانون
الحالي وانا اقر بها كانت موجوده ايضا في
القانون السابق كل ما في الامر هو انه
البعض كان راضيا عن القانون عندما كان
يستجيب لرغباته في قمع المعارضين له لكنهم
الان في موقع المعارضه فهم يشجبون القانون
من منطلق مختلف يعني انا اريد ان يكون
الناس متسقين مع انفسهم ومع قيمهم ومع
مبادئهم وان يرفضوا ما هو خطا في كل
الاحوال وليس فقط عندما يتعلق الامر بهم
هذا قانون فيه الكثير من صح سي ملكن لو
دخلنا في
مقارنه القانون المطروح حاليا ينص لا يجوز
ان يترتب على التظاهر السلميه الاعتصام او
المبيت باماكن او الاخلال بالامن او
النظام العام اما في قانون التظاهر في
عهده الاخوان لم ينص على ذلك صراحه لم
يحضر المبيت او الاعتصام والاعتصام اصلا
هو شكل من اشكال الاحتجاج ال الشرعي الذي
يحق للمواطن ان
يمارسه يعني للاسف انا ممكن اطلع القانون
دلوقتي لكن هياخد مني بعض الوقت علشان
اطلع بالضبط الصيغه الماده القانونيه التي
كانت تحضر نصب الخيام في مواقع المظاهرات
هذا فيع قانون مجج عن لحظه يحضر على
المؤسسات العامه للدوله والخاصه الاعتصام
والتظاهر الذي يترتب عليه تعطيل العمل
والاضرار العمدي بالمصالح الاقتصاديه
للدوله والمواطنين ولا يسمح الا بالتظاهر
الذي لا يتجاوز ثلث عدد عمال المؤسسه بعد
اخطار الجهات الرسميه والامنيه كما تحضر
تحضر التظاهرات الفئويه التي تؤدي الى قطع
الطرق والسكك الحديديه وتعطيل المواصلات
العامه وكل ما من شان الاضرار باحدى وسائل
الانتاج او النقل بالاضافه الىى عدم جواز
تنظيم التظاهرات قبل الساعه السابعه صباحا
على الا تتاخر بعد السابعه ليلا لم اجد
كلمه ممنوع الاعتصام
طيب يعني بعد السابعه ليلا يعني الاعتصام
من الصعب انه الناس تعتصم يعني اذا كان
السابعه ليلا لابد ان تنفض المظاهره يعني
لا يوجد اعتصام الاعتصام معناها الاستمرار
في هذه التظاهر والقا في نفس
المق اليهود اليك لكن ليرد على هذه النقطه
سيد وائل قنديل لانه انتقد اول ما تحدث
تحدث عن نقطه الاعتصام هذه رد عليك هذه
النقطه منصوص عليها في القانون الذي نحن
بصدده الان القانون الح قرات عليكم الكن
في القانون القديم غير منصوص عليها يا يا
استاذ وائل تقول عدم جواز تنظيم تظاهرات
قبل السابعه صباحا على الا تتاخر بعد
السابعه ليلا يعني السابعه عليك ت الى ب ه
هناك ماده تجرم الاعتصام قالت منع
الاعتصام ثانيا انا اريد ان استاذ وائل
اذا كنت انت بعد السابعه ليلا موجود طبيعي
ان تجرم لانك يعني مفروض على السبعه تدخل
الى بيتك هو هنا يتحدث عن المظاهرات التي
تتم وفق اخطار مسبق الفرق بين القانونين
ان هذا القانون الذي نحن بصدده الان ي
يتعامل مع
احتماليات يعني يريد يعني باختصار شديد
يطلب من منظمي هذه المظاهرات الابلاغ عن
المشاركين فيها قبل ان تبدا المظاهرات هو
يطبق عليها عقوبات الاحتمالات وقوع اعمال
عنف وما الى ذلك في القانون القديم كان
يتعامل مع ما سيحدث مع الفعل بعد وقوعه
اما هذا القانون فهو يتعامل مع الفعل قبل
وقوعه و وهو مجرد احتمال في ذهن لا لكن
ينص القانون الحالي فيه ماده تنص صراحه
على ان كل محافظه عليها تخصيص مساحه معينه
عظيم ل يعني يتظاهر فيها الناس بدون اخطار
مساحه مع مساحه محدوده للغايه وعدد محدود
للغايه انا اكلمك عن فكره الاعتصامات
العامه فكره الاعتصام في مصر ارتبطت منذ
25 يناير دائما كان الهتاف اعتصام حتى
يرحل النظام وحتى يسقط النظام وهذا هو ما
استخدمه الفريق عبد الفتاح السيسي وفريق
الانقلاب في الاطاحه بالرئيس محمد مرسي
انهم قرروا الخروج في 30 يونيو والاعتصام
حتى رحيل الرئيس محمد مرسي بل ان الدوله
ممثله في وزير الدفاع او راس هذه الدوله
هو الذي طلب من الجماهير ان تخرج وان
تعتصم وبالتالي ما
كان مباحا لك انت تريد ان تجرمه على
الاخرين الان الفكره من هذا القانون
باختصار شديد هي منع اي احد من التفكير في
فكره تغيير النظام مره اخرى عبر التظ ظهر
السلمي وعبر الاعتصام الذي هو حق مكفول في
الدستور وفي مواثيق حقوق الانسان الدوليه
ولكن حتى في هذه النقطه عندما دعام لتظاهر
وتظاهروا كان كانوا يطبقون هذا القانون
يعني لم يكن هناك سلاح اخطروا قبل يعني
السلطات الحاكمه حاليا معها خبر انهم
يتظاهرون يعني لم يضايقهم بشيء وبتالي من
الذي من الذي كان معه سلاح انت تقول ان
جماعه السيسي
استغلت كانت هنالك تظاهرات استغلها والان
اصدر القانون ويقيد عندما حصل عندما يعني
حصل على مبتغاه لكن التظاهرات التي كانت
لصالحه لم يكن فيها شغب كان فيها شغب وكان
فيها هجوم على القصر الرئاسي وهجوم
بالبلدوزر على القصر الرئاسي وتسلق اسوار
القصر الرئاسي واستخدام المولتوف واحراق
مؤسسات واحراق مركبات كل ذلك شاهدناه
رايناه باعيننا لم لم لم يحكيه احد او لم
يبلغنا به احد نحن رايناه في الشارع وكل
المصريين راوه نحن راينا مذابح في اماكن
اخرى في في القاهره راينا ان هناك من من
يسمى بالمتظاهرين كانت هناك مظاهره
واعتصام استمر اياما وليال على باب وزاره
الدفاع المصريه كان مجموعه المعتصمين
تطارد المواطنين في المواصلات العامه و
وتنزل كل من هو ملتحي او كل من هي منتقبه
وتنكل به وتسحل امام وزاره الدفاع المصريه
تتحدث قبل عزل مرسي عظيم جدا طيب ساعود
اليك ولكن بعد فاصل قصير نواصل بعده
النقاش حول الانتقادات الموجهه لقانون
تنظيم حق التظاهر وقدره الحكومه المصريه
الحاليه على تطبيقه نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش دلالات سعي الحكومه المصريه لاصدار
قانون لتنظيم الحق في التظاهر سيد محمد
سطوحي المجلس القومي لحقوق الانسان في مصر
يقول ان هذا القانون سيصدر لكي يموت بال
القلبيه برايك ما مدى قدره الحكومه على
تطبيق هكذا
قانون دعيني اولا اقف عند نقطه اثارها
الاستاذ وائل وانا كنت بقولت لك انها
موجوده في القانون السابق و وجدتها الان
يحذر على المتظاهرين امام المواقع المبينه
بالماده السابقه وهذه المواقع تشمل كل شيء
تقريبا خطابه او للاذاعه اقامه خيام او
غيرها بغرض المبيت ويجوز لوزير الداخليه
او مدير الامن المختص ان يطلب من النيابه
العامه اصدار الامر بمنع البدء في اي عمل
من هذه الاعمال او انهائها حال بدايتها
يعني المساله كما هو واضح كانت لمنع اي
شيء في اي مكان على الاطلاق الاماكن
المبينه تشمل من القصور الرئاسيه لاماكن
العباده للمنشات الحكوميه لاي شيء في مصر
تقريبا ممنوع الاقتراب منها على مسافه خ
لمسافه 500 متر الاقتراب من كل هذه
المواقع ممكن لمجلس الوزراء ان يضيف اليها
مواقع جديده
حسين
بنتحدى
عرض ووجه بمعارض كنا اول من عرض هذا
القانون كما نعرض هذا القانون الان رغم ان
ما عرض ايام الرئيس محمد مرسي كان اخف وطا
مما هو معروض علينا الان ولم نسمع ان اين
اخف وطاه قرا الماده بوضوح لا هو هو قال
المواد المبينه ولم يذكر لنا المواد
المبينه هو قال كل شيء نريد ان نحدد في
المسكن
يا سيدتي نحن اقراك الاماكن المبينه يا
استاذ وائل طيب لو سمحتلي نحن نتحدث عن
مشروع
ق المجالس التشريعيه
م السفارات
والاتو المحاكم المستشفيات دور العباده
الاثريه وضحت الفكره السيد قنديل يقول
عارض في تلك الايام هذه المواد اجبني عن
سؤال قدره الحكومه المصريه الحاليه على
تطبيق هذا القانون لا سما مع ما قاله
المجلس القومي لحقوق الانسان انه سيصدر
ليموت بالسكته
القلبيه يعني انا شخصيا متحفظ على الكثير
من هذه المواد خصوصا العقوبات المشدده
التي تصل الى 300000 جنيه او السجن لاي
مخالفات بالنسبه لهذه القوانين يعني انا
شخصيا يعني غير راضي عن هذه المواد لكن
يعني علينا ايضا ان نكون منطقيين لا ندافع
عن القانون السابق او نقول انه غير مشابه
للقانون الحالي القانونان متشابهان عندما
نرفض هذا نرفض ذاك يجب ان نكون متفقين مع
انفسنا مساله قدره الحكومه على تطبيقه هذه
مساله اخرى لكن انا اتصور انه يجب ان يكون
هناك توازن في مدخل الحكومه للتعامل مع
هذا الامر ما بين الحفاظ على حقوق الانسان
والحريات العامه وايضا الحفاظ على الامن
لانه يجب ان ن رف ايضا ان هناك اشكاليه هي
انه قبضه الدوله يجب ان تعود قويه لانه
هناك الدوله نفسها كانت معرضه للاهتزاز بل
والسقوط في وقت من الاوقات وبالتالي يجب
ان نحافظ على الدوله وقها
واحترام قمتم بثوره 25 يناير اذا كنت تريد
ان تعود قبض دوله قويه فلنعود الى مبارك
ايضا ما
رايك لا هو يام مبارك كان مجرد التظاهر
اشكاليه يعني نحن الان نتحدث عن حق
التظاهر ولكن عن ضروره تنظيم حق التظاهر
يعني لابد من ابلاغ الحكومه ب مكان هذه
المظاهره الاعداد المتوقعه لها مسيره هذه
المظاهره يجب ان يكون ذلك بالتفاهم مع
السلطات هذا يحدث هنا في الولايات المتحده
اذا خرجت في مظاهره دون تنبيه السلطات
سيتم القاء القبض
عليه لجبهه الانقاذ وحيد عبد المجيد يقول
ان القانون لا يصلح بنصه الحالي من دون
ادخال تعديلا عده
عليه مضبوط يعني انا هذا ما اقوله انه
لابد وانه يجب الحفاظ على حق التظاهر كما
هو ايضا موجود في هذه النصوص التي قراتها
لكن في نفس الوقت يجب الا يكون هناك
مبالغه يعني على سبيل المثال عندما يتم
اعطاء انظار او اختار لجهاز الشرطه
بالمظاهره من يدري انهم سيقولون اننا لم
نستلم على سبيل المثال هذا الاختار يعني
لابد ان يكون هناك قواعد منظمه لتنفيذ هذا
الحق بحيث لا يتم استغلاله من قبل الاجهزه
التنفيذيه لاجهاض حق التظاهر من الاساس ا
سيد القنديل كنت تريد ان تقول شيئ تعليقا
عليه يعني اه ما القانون الذي ينسب الى
الرئيس محمد مرسي لم يكن هناك قانون
للتظاهر كان هناك
مقترحات ومناقشات لماذا لا ن دائما في
مكانت مقارنه سيد وائل لم تتم اح نحن لا
نتحدث عن قانون كان موجودا بالفعل لا يوجد
قانون للتظاهر ا هذه رفضت ورفضتها كل
القوى المعارضه كل
القوى المؤيده لحق التظاهر والدفاع عن حق
المواطنين في في التظاهر والاحتجاج واسقاط
النظام بالتظاهرات السلميه وبالتالي هناك
فرق بين حاله حاله احتمال او مقترح
افتراضي وبين حاله متحققه على الارض الان
ان نحن الان بصدد قانون اقره مجلس
الوزراء ولا يوجد مجلس تشريعي يراقب اداء
الحكومه المصريه مقت هناك رئيس م مؤقت
يتمتع بالسلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه القضائيه
ويتمتع بكل السلطات في يده يستطيع ان يقره
بجرد قلم يعني من قال ان هذا الرئيس
المؤقت احترم دستورا او قانونا او مواثيق
دوليه عندما قرر ان يقتل اكثر من 3000
مواطن مصري في ربعه العدويه نحن نتحدث عن
شخص واحد يحكم مصر بيده بيده مقاليد كل
شيء وبالتالي هو ا اذا اراد ان يقر هذا
القانون بوضعه الحالي سيقرر هذا القانون
ولن ينطق احد يعني نحن الان امام مصر
محكومه الان باراده باراده الفريق عبد
الفتاح السيسي فقط هو لا يريد من احد ان
يكرر ما حدث مع الرئيس محمد مرسي قبل ذلك
وبالتالي يجفف هذا المنبع الذي استخدمه في
الاطاحه بمحمد مرسي لكي يضمن ان احدا لن
يفكر في التظاهر والاعتصام حتى اسقاط
النظام كما هو الشعار المرفوع منذ 25
يناير التي كان مكتسبه الاساسي والوحيد هو
حق المصريين في التعبير حقهم في التظاهر
حقهم في الاعتصام والاضراب وحتى بما في
ذلك المطالبه با انت تقول لن يتحدث احد
الا يعني حتى الان هنالك وحيد عبد المجيد
امين عام مساعد جبه الانقاذ تحدث وانتقد
ايضا مجدي حمدان امين العمل الجماهيري
بحزب جبهه الانقاذ ايضا تحدث وانتقد وقال
هذا
القانون انتقده ومؤكدا تخوف حكومه ببلاوي
من تظاهرات جماعه الاخوان جعلها تقضي على
اي مكتسبات لثوره 25 يناير وترتد
عليها يعني لا يعني واضاف لحظه اضاف ان
القانون الجديد الذي تم اقراره يشبه تماما
القانون الذي تم التصدي له في اثناء حكومه
هشام قنديل ولا ينقصه سوى توقيع قنديل لا
لا هذا كلام غير صحيح على الاطلاق نحن
تحدثنا عن جزئيه الاعتصام لم تكن مجرمه
نصا وبشكل واضح وصريح في قانون هشام قنديل
وانا ايضا لست بصدد المقارنه بين قانونين
لانه يوجد قانون واحد لا يوجد قانون اسمه
قانون هشام هذا كانت مجرد مقترحات مجرد
مسوده
وتتمت معارضتها ولم تحال الى حكومه ولم
تقر حكوميا الان نحن بصدد قانون متحقق
واقره مجلس الوزراء هناك فرق كبير ثانيا
يعني انا لا يحتاج بعد لتوقيع الرئيس
الموقت
سيوقع الرئيس المؤقت ورئيس الحكومه وقع
على قتل 3 الا مصري الن يوقع على قانون
يمنع التظاهر حتى لا يسقط هذا
الرئيس ما موقفك اذا لم يوقع نه لان انا
باختصار شديد لا اعت باي رئيس مؤقت ولا
اعترف بهذه الحكومه المؤقته هذه حكومه
سفاح ونظام صفاح هؤلاء مغتصبون لسلطه
هؤلاء جاؤوا بغير الديمقراطيه جاؤوا غصبا
وجاؤوا قفزا وقرصنه وبالتالي هم يشرع هم
يمتلكون التشريع ويمتلكون القرار ويمتلكون
الاله الماديه للتنفيذ وبالتالي يهم دعم
شعبي سي لا لا فكره الدعم الشعبي يعني لن
نعود
الارقام النهارده يوم عرفه يعني وضح كل شي
مره اخرى شكرا جزيلا الكاتب والمحلل
الصحفي وائل قنديل كنت معنا في الاستديو
اهلا وسهلا بك واشكر السيد محمد سطوحي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ايضا ضيفي من
نيويورك واشكر متابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد فالى
اللقاء
س